today's video we are going to be talking
about how being pretty
is hard think i'm gonna get the girl
he's mad in this video but we're gonna
see
a lot of disadvantages come with being a
conventionally attractive woman so
before we get into this video
sit back chillax get your popcorn out
get your water get your
sea baby okay calm down you're drinking
this honey
all right click that notification bell
hit that subscribe button
and give this video a big thumbs up okay
is that done i hope so
yeah you got a thumbs up for that titty
meet that [ __ ] is omnipresent
and it's half the reason i'm still
watching one point for pretty privilege
carry on i'm mad at you hey you already
know she does look good yo thank you to
whoever picked out
that outfit shout out patrice o'meal yes
go on
okay all right y'all so i got a few
reasons why i say being pretty is hard
y'all don't laugh at me i'm being spiral
from
i'm sorry this is water but it's hard
out here okay
it's right out here for a pimp plus yeah
yeah
it really is girl you speaking to my
soul i don't know if you made this video
for me
but it is hard out here you feel what
i'm saying not for a pimp
before the sim press play you saying man
i mean he's simple
the number one reason why being pretty
is hard y'all love to say
oh my god you're so pretty you get all
the guys whatever okay
getting more guys equals more problems
okay you know if they say mo money mo
problems more dudes more
yo the thought that just came in my head
i can't say that no
maybe i'll caught on to that too
look at every attracted man on this
planet the majority of them
are with very average looking women i'm
sorry i have to say it and then the ugly
guys are the
not conventionally attractive guys i
don't call them ugly they get the
baddies right
now that is because a lot of the
attractive guys
don't want to be an attractive woman
because they know that they be
thoughtting and bopping and they think
the girl will be doing that too no it's
because the average women have better
personalities so after they done
and ran through all the hot girls
they're like man looks ain't doing much
for me so then they meet an average girl
with great personality
yeah this will work i prefer my peace
and quiet because
being a girl with perfect titties it's
just ain't but just used to be just
nagging all the time but you know what
an
ugly dude they never had them titty so
he wife you up real quick and it is what
it is
this girl's out here talking about
pretty privilege
as if it's so hard yeah here's the funny
thing
what do ugly girls do to try to heighten
their looks ugly girls
average girls makeup every girls okay
makeup what else wear
nails sometimes i'll do surgery surgery
yeah at the most surgery to do what
to look better now have you ever heard
of a pretty [ __ ]
scarring her face to look uglier
no to make her life easier no when
she came on this [ __ ] with some makeup
and her titties looking nice
[ __ ] if it's so hard i'm sorry why did
you increase the difficulties
no no how did you come in here talking
about oh my god
oh my god being tall so difficult
[ __ ] you're in heels
how old the titties looking
nah bro hi bro
see this is why oh [ __ ] that thing got
some speechless this is why i'm
marrying an average person because all
you pretty wavin
you you're you're so lost in the sauce
yeah i'm too i'm too nice let me pour
some acid on me you imagine being
married to someone who's this big of an
airhead
i can only look at your titties for so
long
and then after that i gotta listen to
stupid [ __ ] like this
she's like it's because it's not because
you're intimidating
it's not because you're intimidating no
it's not they don't settle down with you
because
your vagina is not a substitute for
personality or sometimes they just don't
want to talk to you it's like that yes
it depends what truth is great it
depends what you display this depends
what
what the vibe and everything is of it i
don't think the people that are you
think or intimidated by you
they're not the hot dudes see a are not
being intimidated by you but you know
your experience you tell me
but i i'm just judging by this video
your lack of self-awareness is
through the roof yes hey you want to
clean up
cool you can use creams nah
conventional blades ouch why complicated
task when manscape has a tool for you
the lawnmower 4.0 ceramic blades plus
skin safe technology wireless
charging and also waterproof
visit manscape.com that's mnscpd.com
a-b-a-a-n-d preach that's
abba and preach and get 20 off plus free
shipping
with that code the code abba and preach
on manscape.com
get yours today yo i'm preaching here
tell me that's not the truth
hey hey don't be using my name in vain
man and this girl
don't be using my name in vain listen i
drink the saudi water out of necessity
this girl slurping on it like it's a
delicacy yeah it's a delicacy oysters
right here
slurp slurp no it's designing yo she got
basically coca-cola in the bar i know 10
crits i saw that
drink pork
come on come on you know what the
signing is
i'm gonna tell you what this sauna is
it's coca-cola water they strip the
water of all the minerals
it doesn't taste bad but it's not good
it's not a delicacy
no no but if someone offers me about
i'll drink it whatever yeah whatever
it's there
but i'm not gonna it's not a delicacy
man listen
i drink it just hoping it's got some
kind of like mutant formula you ever
think like getting super powers
you get like you know how you fall in
toxic waste sometimes i get that
water you drink plant water and it's all
sudden yeah yeah you just grow some
wings you become super
when you have more guys that you have to
deal with y'all
it's a lot okay that means more likely
to get your heart broken
but i don't like to date attractive men
and
like very attractive men i like a solid
seven like you know like you know they
always like the cute ugly guys
i need like a solid seven seven point
five you two fine i can't do it okay
because
i feel like that's what leads to like
getting your heart broken all the time
is this the thing
is what she say anything yeah 100 okay
would you know why you're attracted
this is security office team this is
security
if you go for a top dude and he got 100
other girls hollering
like he's not going to really stick with
competitors ladies at the other day they
want security
but the thing is what she's complaining
about this is what i'm clean is
i have too many options i have too many
freedoms
guys life is so hard when you have all
these choices i just don't know what to
pick meanwhile you got ladies in saudi
arabia being like
can i please drive and it's so this is
like
you want me to feel bad for you press
play i feel like it's way easier
to find an attractive girl than is to
find an attractive guy so when you find
that attractive guy when all of us women
find that one attractive guy we all want
him
and he likes that attention most times
nine out of ten times they do love that
attention
so it's gonna be very hard to find a
faithful very trying guy so i just kind
of like
protect my heart by not dating
attractive guys but we have so many men
that constantly are coming to us when
they talk to us so say we get the
the you know average dude we get the
average guy right the average guy
thinks that we get all these attractive
guys or things we get so many guys which
we may or may not get
so that leads them to act up too you
said earlier that you were getting more
guys
you confirmed it like a donkey perm
don't they say mo money mo problems more
dudes more you i tuned into this video
and i saw that titty me and you had me
okay so i can only imagine what kind of
thirst traps
are on your instagram right now let's go
check
i don't know why any guy would be like
bro we didn't even yo
you diddy yo you didn't even win like
this you went left
and this but you know what yo listen
have the meat out i ain't your man i am
mad at it live your life
because guys a lot of time they will get
like intimidated by being with somebody
like me like they think i'm doing all
this stuff when i'm really not like i'll
let you think i am
but i really am not i'm a loyal girl i
don't have to do that much that's
another thing i'm really loyal but
people think because i am like a pretty
girl that
i'm talking to all these dudes when i'm
not probably because you're advertising
and you're
thirsting for attention just saying if
you're out there broadcasting and
looking for that attention using that
guys are probably going to assume that
you're talking to a lot of dudes same
way for dude who's out there person
posting their straps with his abs out
and his [ __ ] pectorals looking all
buff
you would think there's a lot of girls
talking to him you literally said
earlier that if a dude is pretty you
just
assume that he's talking to a lot of
women why because you assume that he
likes it and so he indulges
it's the same thing with dudes and
seeing girls doing thirst traps exact
same thing listen you're not debunking
pretty privilege
you're just you're just saying that
despite having this pretty privilege
my life can still have difficulties
privilege doesn't mean that your life is
inherently easy
it just means that it's easier there's a
difference between the two
it's kind of frustrating because i feel
like like i know like a guy will think
oh yeah she's cute
whatever you know she batty whatever
like i think that guys definitely do say
that about me
but i also think that they're not gonna
come and approach me because they're
like
nah like she's doing her like it's it
it's crazy
like i said i've had plenty of
opportunities that i could talk to
attractive guys
but i just don't want to and they just
don't
want to date girls at their level that's
so makes it hard being
pretty that's another reason and it's
difficult because sometimes you do want
to find me in here or there but you know
they they they don't want to be there
there
you know so yeah so another reason why
i'll say being pretty is hard is because
i feel like you also get a lot more
haters
so when it comes to being attractive
people tend to think that you always
think that you're this hot stuff
now don't get me wrong i do think i'm
the ish okay
but i do it
ah dude
some of these girls think that they're
really hotter than this don't get me
wrong i really think i'm really hot
i'm not doing
no we i think we're good okay we don't
think we summed it up all right
i mean
i'm gonna say this okay i'm gonna rank
my privileges
by order okay all right this is what
these juice
and feed sorry go ahead so these are my
top privileges from top to bottom all
right ranking number one this is my
honest to god opinion
the best privilege in the world is
financial privilege
if you're born into a wealthy background
if you're born into a first world
country
you're already beating most people okay
there is nothing better
all right you either want to be a poor
ass white south african
okay or you want to be the a rich black
person in america i already know which
one i'm picking
nine times out of ten ten times out of
ten one
two the second best privilege in this
world it
looks privileged if you pretty if you
attract if you handsome
it's one of the best privileges higher
odds of job better response from people
more privileges throughout your life
better odds of success
the stats on being attractive are
phenomenal
okay life is just easier
if you're more and the third privilege
this privilege
is underrated i put this on my personal
number one
me purse but this is able body privilege
i mean having all my limbs working
you imagine trying to jerk off with no
arms [ __ ]
you imagine trying to mack on a girl and
you got no legs
you got you you gotta roll up on her you
know i mean chilling there
they see me you know it's just you're
right i
and then i'll put white privilege on
number four number four
would you rather be able-bodied
but a minority or disabled
and what
go ahead i'll wait
i i want to be able by you dude
if i'm lying go ahead no i i think no
don't know how to be honest okay hey
take these bullets
i'm just saying it's fact would you
rather be an ugly white person or a very
attractive minority
you want to be a [ __ ] hobbit who who
looks like frodo
and white hairy feet or
naomi campbell i'm a dude naomi campbell
okay all the time sex change every time
use whatever bathroom let's go
okay go on a korean spot right now let's
do this let's let's go
what would you rather be a poor white
dude or a rich
[ __ ] did you say they own me campbell
because of the forehead game
hey man i always gotta show it to my 48
people i'm just saying so
so for me like yo the pretty privilege
is a real thing she didn't do anything
debunked in fact
just the mere fact that she can have a
youtube channel would be that popular
and her lack that much self-awareness
is indicative of the fact that she
didn't mean
privilege yes sir that's right after
them right that's under a white
privilege because they're not following
under
under white privilege you got kidding me
they're not falling for your personality
i'm just saying so
it is what it is it is what it is let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below were we too harsh
or am i lying i'm just saying all these
pretty women talking about oh my god
it's so hard
[ __ ] there's knives in your kitchen you
can fix that situation real quick
none of y'all doing that y'all still
rocking makeup y'all still hitting the
gym
cause y'all know deep down inside that
being more attractive makes life easier
so let's stop the cap let's stop lying
because we all know what's up
we good we good all right stop playing
with it
me looking
[Music]
good
is
[Music]